uh let's just bring you some breaking
news we understand that the prime
minister boris johnson has just received
his booster jab in his news conference
earlier on uh updating the country on
the new variant of kovid omicron he
mentioned that he was going for his jab
on thursday he's made space in his busy
diary and here it is the prime minister
uh very much walking the walk as well as
talking the talk and going for his third
jab his booster uh
in the fight against covid 19.
i think he's uh talking to some of the
people that are there in that cubicle
with him that's listening
so these are the latest pictures we have
of the prime minister heading for his
booster jab the government are saying
that the booster vaccination program is
the best line of defense as we enter the
festive period we've been discussing
throughout the programme this afternoon
um
that christmas parties are in doubt the
government is saying continue as usual
continue
to have your festive period as you had
planned
but as we were hearing there's some
confusion
as to whether people should be having
big gatherings um the government are
saying it's okay but we're hearing
already that businesses are suffering
with people cancelling or postponing
christmas parties until they feel a
little bit more reassured to do so until
we know a bit more about this new
variant so that is uh boris johnson
receiving his booster
jab
earlier on today in london
he spoke
a few minutes
after receiving the jab
restaurants tell us people are
cancelling christmas parties schools and
nurseries are having nativities behind
closed doors prime minister
people are confused can you clear things
up for them yes the most important thing
is that people should follow the
guidance we've set out and
people shouldn't be cancelling things
and
there's there's no need for that at all
that's not in
what we're saying
what we're doing is trying to respond in
a in a balanced and a proportionate way
to the to the arrival of the omicron
variant and we're focusing particularly
on on transport on travel uh so tough
measures for uh for anybody who comes
into this country very tough measures to
be able to come in uh some rules about
self-isolation if you come into contact
with somebody who has omicron and some
some toughening of the rules on mars but
otherwise we want people to to continue
as they are the most important thing you
can do under all circumstances is get
your booster uh when you when you're
eligible so we're doing all the over 40s
now i've just had mine
my date was was due today
and
uh we've done 18.6 million
booster jabs in this country so we're
building ever higher the wall of
protection whatever omicron may or may
not be able to to do it certainly will
not negate the overall value of the of
the boosters so everybody should get
your your booster as soon as you're
caught forward uh we're buying more uh
more more fisa more more modern another
114 million doses that we're buying and
everybody
will be everybody over 18 will be
offered a boost by the end of january so
okay to snog this christmas are you
holding a christmas party will you go
ahead with that we are getting on we had
events uh
the whole time we had event for annika
we turned the christmas lights on and
all sorts of things in in number 10
and in accordance with the rules as as
you would expect and what i want to say
to people is
you know please do we've got we've got
to take a balance and a proportionate
approach to this we've we've taken some
particular measures that are that are
designed to tackle the the risk that we
see from
omicron and that's it and that i think
is the responsible thing to do but under
all circumstances what you need to do is
get your is get your booster do you
understand why people are confused
all i'm saying is people need to get
their boosts okay just about parties
there's obviously been a lot of news
about last year's parties and i just
want to ask you you said no rules were
broken which is fine why didn't you just
make this story go away and tell us what
happened
because i've i've told you and uh what i
want to repeat that
the guidance is there
and
i'm you know very very
keen that people understand this uh we
don't want people to feel that they need
to start cancelling things to to start
but you talk about kids in the nativity
plays and that kind of things i don't
think there's any need to to stop that
at all and i want
i i as i've said many times before i
think we're taking a balanced and
proportionate approach to the to the
risk but i want and i believe that
christmas this year will be considerably
better than christmas last year that
didn't address the question but anyway
you want me to i know you want to talk
about this quickly what are you doing to
help people affected by storm irwin yes
so on on storm irwin uh and i just first
of all i want to say
uh how desperate it must have been for
people must still be for people uh to be
out of power uh for so long uh what
we're doing is is sending the army to
their that we've got about 100 134
troops up in the the grampian region of
scotland helped with about three
thousand homes that got power outages uh
every every day we're reducing the
numbers of people who have the outages
but you know a lot of people have been
out of power for a long time it was a a
very very big storm
uh we're doing everything we can to help
people i think i think there were about
19 000 homes without uh this morning
where we've got that down to about 16
000. that's no consolation to the 16 000
uh who are still suffering but we're
working flat out to help you